[Musique]
toutabo les chasser je suis quelque part
la télévision il ya des spectateurs qui
sont là ya un type qui est cordonnier
regarde le lundi cheveux l'émission
contre les juifs raison mardi contre les
anciens combattants mercredi contre les
noirs le jeudi contre
les riches entre la gauche et smart
contre la droite
taper dessus quand on est militaire et
il a raison contre les curés il a dû je
me fous des cordonniers coelho monsieur
vous avez aux humains du cordonnier
c'est tout faut pas tomber dans la zone
des gens et ça vous êtes arrivé à vous
raconter une histoire supposé drôle sans
soin faut dire que moi j'avais des
numéros qui cherchait particulièrement
d'oublier du cheval je dressais les
postes ils veulent d'abord mon premier
numéro dont il a taclé par le régime
je vais car notre rival datable je
voudrais faire un numéro de dressage
comme vous j'ai posé les fondations
ça ne faisait pas hurler de rire parce
que c'était quand même conditionné
disons que le casse croûte et a
directement conditionnée à celle ci je
pense vraiment trop de buts les jours
tous les objets que personne n'apprend
avec qui je vais pouvoir aller parier
wall est porté de cajou mais maintenant
on pas tout le temps une fois temps en
temps c'est une grande volupté arrivée
faire tout un numéro et puis ne pas voir
une réaction voire des grands lits
ouverts le pâle lueur de volupté moi
j'ai toujours rêvé
je ne peux pas je me suis si vous
laissez jean attitude là je me suis
dégonflé de faire une carrière sérieuse
pendant 40 ans voire même politique
pour pouvoir un jour à la tribune de
l'assemblée en fin de carrière faire le
dernier disque ouvre et tournai le
président c'est d'un ton ému le coeur
serré que je lui dire tu la vie vaut
aussi pour faire une feinte quoi je
trouve cela vaut le coup d'attendre
pendant 40 ans pour dire ça oui un
personnage trois records dans le domaine
de la culture que je citerai pas mais
qui a joué aux obsèques d'un grand
peintre a prononcé un discours en disant
devant le catafalque et tu es là étendue
maintenant toi tu vois savent plus
comment ils stockent les toits l'a
étendu l'étendue là toi mon cher grillé
mi-temps on sérieusement dans la barre
ce qui est drôle c'est pas la barre ce
mot pardon après quand on le sait quand
on s'excuse on sait jamais la voir la
gorce qui elle même est rigolote
c'est quand le type de personne qui l'a
fait une greffe s'embrouille 120 gb bat
et il raconte ne porte jamais une très
belle qui était fait on n'est plus que
de ses amis qui étaient mortes du raid a
rencontré sa mère
ça m'avait dit vous n'êtes pas venus à
l'enterrement a dit non j'ai été pas
l'hymne sans s'arrêter avec plaisir il
super parce que ça part d'un bon
sentiment
vous vous souvenez d'une de vos gains
non non moi j'en ai fait pas mal comme
ça j'en fais tout le temps moi mais moi
j'en suis tout le temps parce que je
m'occupe
je ne sais jamais qui sont les gens qui
m'arrêtent et les gens me disent
toujours vous souvenez moi je dis
toujours oui je sais jamais si c'est non
ce que ce que j'ai fait une fois avec un
ticket producteurs à la télévision c'est
que j'ai dit bonjour de loin ou gap la
presse et approcher puis il m'a dit j'ai
faim aujourd'hui je pense à lui et puis
est venue et puis manu mais qu'est ce
qu'il ya où il fait la tête je lui ai
dit non non non excusez moi j'ai mais je
vous avais pris pour satan intel il veut
maintenant les gens si vous voulez ne
relève pas suffisamment leurs erreurs je
crois un petit canton canton il faut de
temps en temps c'est bien mais je suis
fou je fais n'importe quoi c'est comme
ça qu'on arrive à supporter un plus moi
j'ai fait c'est dans ces trucs idiots ya
pas tellement longtemps chez moi je suis
arrivé un soir
le réfrigérateur j'ai sorti un pot de
yaourt
j'ai retiré le papier d'aluminium
j'ai des futures j'ai lavé la couette
je ne sais pas pourquoi dans ce coup je
me suis dit mais qui a foutu s'est revu
leur feu vert
[Musique]